la jurisdicción especial para la paz
aceleran sus investigaciones sobre la
guerra en colombia este martes fue el
turno nuevamente de la extinta guerrilla
de las farc a la que investigara por
haber reclutado 18 mil 667 menores de
edad en 50 años de forma sistemática es
sin duda alguna uno de los hechos más
graves que se han podido cometer en el
conflicto el reclutamiento de menores de
14 años viola el derecho internacional
humanitario también se van a investigar
crímenes internacionales como
desaparición forzada homicidio y
violencia sexual en niños y niñas
mayores y menores de 15 años fueron
víctimas de conductas que afectaron su
autonomía y su integridad sexual tales
como abortos forzados anticoncepción
forzada acceso carnal violento o acceso
carnal abusivo la investigación se
centrará especialmente entre 1996 y 2006
período en el que se dice que hubo más
reclutamiento forzado 26 ex combatientes
han sido llamados a dar su versión
voluntaria mientras que firmantes del
acuerdo de paz de las farc que suelen
negar que él fuera una política
emitieron un comunicado tras recibir el
auto 159 procederemos a realizar el
estudio juicioso del mismo junto a
nuestro equipo de defensa y nos
pronunciaremos prontamente la
jurisdicción especial para la paz forma
parte del sistema integral para la paz
junto a la comisión de la verdad y la
unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas es el resultado de los
acuerdos entre el gobierno y las farc en
el año 2016 en las últimas semanas ha
imputado crímenes de guerra militares
que habrían ejecutado extrajudicialmente
a 6 mil 400 civiles lo que se conoce
como 'falsos positivos' antes la gp
también había imputado a ex guerrilleros
por más de 21 mil secuestros